>>> BRAND-NEW VIDEO INTO CNN
THIS IS PICTURES OF RUSSIAN
TANKS KING UP POSITIONS
APPARENTLY ON THE STREETS OF
IRPIN, THE CITY JUST WEST OF
KYIV WHERE WE HAVE SEEN THEM
ACTUALLY SHELLING CIVILIANS ON
KNOWN EVACUATION ROUTES.
THIS SEEMS TO SHOW AT LEAST FIVE
TANKS AND THEIR CREWS WITHIN
YARDS OF THESE CIVILIAN
APARTMENTS.
WE WILL KEEP OUR EYE ON THIS AND
BRING YOU MUCH MORE WHEN WE GET
IT IN.
>>> JOINING ME NOW IS THE FORMER
PRESIDENT OF UKRAINE, PETRO
POROSHENKO.
MR. PRESIDENT, THANK YOU SO MUCH
FOR BEING WITH US.
WE'VE SEEN CIVILIANS HIT ALONG
THESE WELL-KNOWN EVACUATION
ROUTES FROM UKRAINIAN CITIES.
DO YOU BELIEVE THE RUSSIANS ARE
TARGETING CIVILIANS?
>> DEFINITELY.
AND WE HAVE ABSOLUTELY CLEAR
EVIDENCE OF THAT.
BECAUSE OUR BATTALION, YOU SEE
THE SOLDIERS OF THESE BATTALIONS
YESTERDAY AND DAY BEFORE
YESTERDAY WAS RESPONSIBLE FOR
STORMING.
WE EVACUATE 2,500 CHILDREN AND
WOMEN.
AND WE SEE WITH OUR OWN EYES
THEIR ATTACK WITH THE MORTAR AND
ARTILLERY.
CIVILIANS WERE TRYING TO LEAVE
THE CITY.
AND THIS IS THE ACT OF THEIR
BLOODY KILLER PUTIN.
WE SEE, FOR EXAMPLE, THE MAYOR
YURI AND TWO VOLUNTEERS.
WE KNOW THEM.
THEY WERE KILLED DURING THE
DISTRIBUTION OF FOOD AND
MEDICINE.
DIRECT FIRE.
THAT IS HAPPENING.
THE SAME IN BUCCA WHERE PEOPLE
ARE TRYING TO ASSIST WITH
HUMANITARIAN AID WHO WERE
DIRECTLY KILLED BY RUSSIAN
SOLDIERS.
WE HAVE FAMILIES GOING TO OUR
BUS WHICH WAS PROTECTED WITH OUR
SOLDIERS.
THEY OPENED ARTILLERY FIRE, AND
THE FAMILY, THE FATHER, MOTHER,
AND TWO CHILDREN RIGHT IN FRONT
OF OUR BATTALION WERE KILLED.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO SEE THAT.
AND THIS IS -- THEY TRIED TO
ERASE WHOLE CITIES.
AND THE SAME SITUATION IS IN
MARIUPOL, KHARKIV.
THIS PICTURE IS MUCH WORSE THAN
OWE LESSEN POE DURING THE HITLER
ATTACK.
THIS IS NO DIFFERENT.
I WANT TO THANK CNN, THE WESTERN
MEDIA, FOR DEMONSTRATING THE
TRUTH ABOUT RUSSIA.
AND THIS IS JUST TO MAKE MORE
RESPONSIBILITY FOR THE PUTIN,
DEFINITELY WILL HAVE APPEARED ON
THE INTERNATIONAL CRIMINAL
COURT.
WE HAVE OTHER THINGS.
YESTERDAY IT WAS SEVERAL RUSSIAN
MILITARY JET AND THE PILOT,
RUSSIAN PILOT WHICH WERE IN THIS
JET.
WE HAVE -- THEY GIVE EVIDENCE
THAT IT IS THE SAME PILOT WHO
WAS BOMBING SYRIA.
NOW THEY ARE BOMBING MYKOLAIV,
KHARKIV, AND IRPIN.
WE HAVE SOLDIERS WHO HIT IT
THROUGH THE RUSSIAN MILITARY JET
AND DELIVERING THE EVIDENCE
ABOUT THAT.
THIS IS THE REAL VICTIMS.
AND THE NUMBER OF VICTIMS IS
HUNDREDS AND HUNDREDS OF
CIVILIANS WHO WERE KILLED BY
RUSSIAN ARTILLERY FIRE, RUSSIAN
TANKS, AND RUSSIAN SOLDIERS
DIRECTED BY ANOTHER COMPLETE MAD
MAN WHOSE NAME IS PUTIN.
THIS IS A WAR NOT AGAINST
UKRAINE.
AND EVERYBODY SHOULD UNDERSTAND
THAT.
THIS IS THE WAR AGAINST
COLLECTIVE WEST.
THIS IS A WAR AGAINST U.S.,
NATO, A WAR AGAINST EUROPE, A
WAR AGAINST THE WHOLE WORLD.
AND HE WANTS TO DESTROY NOT ONLY
UKRAINE.
HE WANTS TO DESTROY OUR VALUES.
HE WANTS TO DESTROY ANY NATION
IN EUROPEAN CONTINENT.
AND THAT'S WHY WHEN YOU ASSIST
UKRAINE BY SUPPLYING DEFENSIVE
WEAPONS, BY SUPPLYING THE ROCKET
LAUNCHER WHICH WE NEED TO KEEP
THE LEVEL OF UKRAINIAN ARMY ON
THE SAME LEVEL.
WE DEFINITELY NEED IT.
AND THIS IS MY SPECIAL REQUEST.
WE NEED JET SWAP.
PLEASE SUPPLY TO POLAND, TO
GERMANY, SLAVIC REPUBLIC, JETS
FROM NATO AND DELIVER US OLD
SOVIET PLANES.
WE DON'T NEED YOUR SOLDIERS.
WE DON'T NEED YOUR PILOTS.
WE NEED JUST JETS TO KEEP THE
AIRSPACE ABOVE US SECURE.
>> RIGHT.
>> THE AIRSPACE ABOVE THE
NUCLEAR POWER STATION, AIRSPACE
ABOVE CIVILIANS AND UKRAINE.
IN U.S., 70% OF THE PEOPLE
SUPPORT IT.
IN EUROPE, 70% OF PEOPLE SUPPORT
IT.
WE ARE A DEMOCRATIC NATION.
PLEASE LET'S AT LEAST DO THE
DECISIVE DECISION.
>> TALKING ABOUT GETTING MIGS
FROM POLAND AND REPLACING THEM
IN POLAND WITH OTHER PLANES,
SENDING THE MIGS INTO UKRAINE TO
BE USED THERE.
JUST SO PEOPLE KNOW THE AREAS
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, THEY ARE
JUST OUTSIDE KYIV RIGHT NOW.
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU'VE BEEN ON
THE STREETS IN THE TERRITORIAL
DEFENSE.
DO YOU HAVE A SENSE THE RUSSIANS
ARE CLOSING IN ON KYIV THIS
MORNING?
>> DECISIVE AND BRAVE UKRAINIAN
SOLDIERS GIVING THEIR BLOOD AND
THEIR LIVES TO KEEP RUSSIA THE
SAME DISTANCE.
BUT RUSSIA INCREASING THE
PRESSURE ON KYIV -- (INAUDIBLE).
40 MINUTES AGO THEY TURN BACK
WHERE WE DELIVER THE WEAPONS,
AMMUNITION AND UNIFORM TO THE
BATTALION OF THE TERRITORIAL
DEFENSE TO TRY TO PROTECT US
FROM THIS DIRECTION.
WE HAVE 206 BATTALION TO KEEP IT
IN THE BUCCA DIRECTION.
WE LOST A HERO YESTERDAY.
AND THE DAY BEFORE YESTERDAY.
WITH THIS SITUATION, DEFINITELY
WE STILL ARE KEEPING THE RUSSIAN
TROOPS ON THE POSITION.
BUT WE HAVE 17 CRUISE MISSILES
FOR KYIV, TOGETHER WITH AIRBORNE
AND DEFINITELY WE NEED TO
PROTECT OUR CAPABILITIES FROM
THE AIR.
BUT DEFINITELY THE SITUATION IS
QUITE DIFFICULT.
AND WE NEED FOR THE WEAPONS.
AND BY THE WAY WE NEED FOR THE
SANCTION.
AGAIN, 50% OF AMERICANS CONSIDER
A SANCTION IS NOT ENOUGH.
AND EVERY SINGLE DAY, WHILE
PUTIN KEEPS THE POSSIBILITY TO
ATTACK US, HE SHOULD KNOW THAT
EVERY SINGLE DAY SANCTIONS WILL
START TO BE STRONGER AND
STRONGER.
FOR EXAMPLE, THE -- WHY WE
SHOULD FINANCE PUTIN THROUGH THE
BUYING EVEN WITH A DISCOUNT THE
RUSSIAN EURO'S OIL.
WITH THAT SITUATION I THINK THIS
IS SIMPLY IMMORAL.
PUTIN SHOULD DEFINITELY HEED THE
'EM BAR TPWOE OF OIL.
WHY EUROPE PAY FOR THEM DOLLARS
FOR SUPPLYING THE RUSSIAN GAS
EVERY SEASON DOLLAR, TRANCE
NATIONAL CORPORATION WILL BE A
DOLLAR SPENT FOR KILLING US
UKRAINIANS.
WE SHOULDN'T ALLOW THAT.
WE SHOULD KEEP TOGETHER.
WE ARE VERY MUCH MIRED WITH THE
UNITED STATES, WITH THE
LEADERSHIP OF PRESIDENT BIDEN,
WITH YOUR LEADERSHIP, THE
LEADERSHIP OF YOUR
ADMINISTRATION OF YOUR CONGRESS,
LET'S DO NOT STOP.
LET'S GO FURTHER.
THIS IS THE MOMENT OF TRUTH.
AND WITH THIS MOMENT OF TRUTH,
PUTIN SHOULD BE -- SHO